until 11.
by the way you look
stunning thank you I can't believe we're
finally together and I was like can I
start with Gertie loves 11. 11 is like
UT in every way and like she it feels
like more of a feminine ET but somebody
who falls from another planet and is
completely molded by the people around
her and oh my gosh I can't believe I'm
here also watch the show religiously so
it's like a really big deal to be on it
and I have been watching Enola Holmes
religiously do you love it I love it so
much I love this
oh my gosh yeah wait are we at a red
light I'm gonna ask you a question okay
okay do you do English accents can you
do one of anola I do I do
um I had to learn Forever After but
there are definitely it was more of a
royal pronunciation yes and I loved uh
studying for Edie Beale who definitely
talks like with a very strange voice
is there an accent you can't do or that
you're intimidated to do oh this is a
good question because I I obviously I do
my I I do my basically the Australian
accent can go really far back in your
throat and then the English accent's
like middle yes and then the Americans
all in the mouth and it's all very like
easy coloring I get intimidated with
certain English accents my dad he's from
the countryside so he's kind of he
doesn't talk like a farmer but a farmer
in England which is a very different
thing here and what does it sound like
it idea that's the one I can't do
you've caught me is it true you like
love Island I love love Island tell me
why tell me everything have you watched
it is it the one where they put the
microphones on the bikini yes okay
that's my favorite detail that they and
they have to like when they're in the
pool
yes they're like necklaces it's my
favorite me and Noah schnapp who's in
stranger things kiwi on our show he's
the best I mean we were always able to
kind of connect with each other and it's
so platonic which is so beautiful stay
with me and Sandler yeah never kiss and
Jake by the way who's my boyfriend he
when we first met Jake was like you guys
are in love but it's in the most
platonic way you're walking down the
street does everybody want the secrets
and what do they tell you about not
talking about the secret he got so many
lengthy emails like no you cannot say
this you can't say that but you know a
lot of people come down the street like
can you do the pose some kids actually
think I have powers but I actually have
the tattoo I got the tattoo
which um by the way these are all my
cats I like get scratched constantly I
have like 10 cats and you have a bunny I
do have a rabbit his name's EO because
he's a French lip so he's really big all
of my animals have character names I
have Winnie the Pooh and I have Maximus
Meridius for Gladiator Russell Crowe
yeah
you have the best relationship what's a
red flag to pay attention to and love
um uh men with umbrellas
I mean it's also an egg but a super red
flag don't hold on brother I can hold my
own these were not what I would have
expected at all I went on a date with a
guy and he's like you're gonna have to
lose the Hat where we're going had the
dress code I go are you kidding me was
the worst date ever yeah no I would have
left then in that like it to me like I
should have I already knew I loved you
but I'm so in love with you
oh red light
what is your worst fear you know I had a
really bad fear of that when I was
filming I had a dream that I was on
stranger things and I couldn't stop
looking at camera and that was a really
big fear of mine like I almost wanted to
vomit imagine 11 just turns to camera
mid take it's doing it to the camera
like I also need to compliment you the
Enola homes movies mean so much to me I
can't handle how difficult breaking down
the fourth wall is yeah and talking the
camera and I think you are literally the
best I've ever seen at it oh my gosh I
think it all has to do with the fact
that I just grew up in front of a camera
so I feel really comfortable with
cameras I am so glad that you said
because it made me feel so less alone as
I've always talked about how a camera is
my friend yeah and this is Ronnie Ronnie
this is a huge deal for me I am freaking
out I like I'm obsessed with your shot
okay wait then that is a Perfect Cue for
Ronnie's review so Alona homes too who
doesn't love a great mystery yeah like
it was adventurous thrilling pact of
faction I truly enjoyed it I was on the
edge of my seat for quite some time and
uh there should be no shortage of
mysteries for Alona to solve going
forward nobody knows this the kissing
scene blue he looked at me and he was
like so like we'll just do it on the
fast take and I was like dude like it's
not a big deal like my fast kiss was in
front of my dad on screen write it up
like nothing phases me at this point and
I was like like it's fine rehearsal I
just let you know he's so nervous I just
rubbed him and just gave him a kiss and
he was like and that is so Enola to me
what would you like to do next or even
if it's in 10 years what's something on
your bucket list of the producer and a
filmmaker I want to play a real person
and I think for me Brittany
would be Britney Spears can I ask why I
think her story
festival resonates with with me just
growing up in the public eye watching
her videos watching interviews of how
when she was younger I mean same thing
with you it's like I see the Scramble
for words and I don't know her but when
I look at pictures of her I feel like I
could I could tell her story in the
right way in hers only
I've looked forward to a moment like
this I've wished it I've manifested it
but as just a human to human you are so
wise so magnanimous so freaking cool
thank you so much I'm taking my seatbelt
off too now
that's the interview I've ever ever done
Long Live A nola home yes
don't forget to leave me a review
[Music]